are you let me ask you something
dump dump dump dump found it let me ask
you something okay
when you met my brother are ten years
ago back to you know in the day when you
guys were like doing shows together and
whatnot what do you think my brother's
talented yeah I mean well the rap style
during that time with a lot more
abstract like the underground scene and
I always thought like Stevie Styles very
like abstract you know I actually come
from that to like our world of hip-hop
was a very like abstract style Wow cuz
we were like kind of nerdy kids you know
yeah and it wasn't like you know the
rapper Tech typical rapper image
necessarily you know we were just trying
to be like all like intricate we are
right you know so but so my brother does
have skill yeah yeah yeah he was unique
yeah he is a unique I think that was the
main thing it's like in hip-hop like
it's more important that you're like
different they're like you know well
that that that gives me a sense of pride
then yeah you should know really because
my brother and I are I don't come from
that world right you know when I started
you know when I was growing up I
listened to the Beatles
yeah yeah and the Velvet Underground and
like just kind of bands I was never
exposed to hip-hop much I think you know
back in my day I think I bought a day
lost so album you know tribe album stuff
like that but um Fuji's you know but
that's as deep as I went right now and I
feel I feel kind of guilty almost it's
not as if I didn't want to it's just
that it just wasn't the stuff that
people were listening to in the 80s it
where I grew up
right for some reason my brother was
exposed to that you know and so I don't
know much about it and so I never really
when my brother said that he wanted to
pursue it professionally I was just I
was like yeah go do it whatever if you
feel happy about it but I could never
tell if he was good or not didn't know
like reference yeah cuz I've no
reference right so just keep doing but
then when I see him now with his new
band with monkey he I could see
his performance style right he can
perform he's brave
yeah and he is original he aims he is
his himself
he's definitely fearless in this new
band situation yeah you know I mean like
just going in and is an [ __ ] hanging
out there and I think it's it yeah and
it's it looks way I remember seeing him
perform he was already fearless then
yeah but this time around I think it's
that the music is more even unique than
then really Wow yeah yeah and they just
allowed him to I mean but his rap style
is kind of similar actually
yeah just applying it to like van you
know yeah yeah it's really fun to watch
I mean I see his [ __ ] it has right I
remember one show I was just staring at
my brother's ass I've never seen him
really before you know that clearly
performing performing but I thought to
myself he's got my dad nice he's got a
nice ass I think I have my more my mom's
oh I don't know what your mom's ass
looks like it's not that good you have a
cute butt thank you nice butts
yes DB has a girl but I know it's a
curves yeah I know I want that no these
are exercises I can do yeah yeah oh
really in that little protrude my
butthole boy you're about to be bigger
or your butthole - I want my butthole to
stick out a little bit like you're
better you want it like it's puckering
didn't lips on his butt oh yeah yeah I
wanna I want his mouth a little on the
top a little thicker on the bottom yeah
[Music]